it is now my honor to introduce a man
who has been a source of continued
inspiration to me over my three years at
hillsdale college each year dr david
weyland introduces the freshman to the
terror in the best sense of the word of
a true liberal arts education in a
speech in which he warns us all that
hillsdale is out to shape our hearts
and our minds when i first heard that
speech it challenged and excited me and
i've made its point to go back and watch
that speech each of the following years
dr whalen obtained his phd in english
literature from the university of kansas
and currently serves as provost and
professor of english at hillsdale
college dr whalen has taught at the
university of kansas and belmont abbey
college and the topics of his published
articles include renaissance poetry
educational philosophy and the writings
of john henry newman
dr whalen and his wife janet have 11
children and live in quincy michigan
he's a truly liberal educated man
and it gives me great pleasure to be
able to hear him speak once again please
welcome dr whalen
thank you jacob
i have it on very good authority that
the best approach to this topic is
simply to say
it's over despair go home
but i won't i won't
in fact that there was a very kind
introduction
not
all 11 children are presently at home i
see one in this room
but i also see a number of people in
this room who could probably give a talk
on the current
travails in higher education
as well or better than i so uh
pardon all of my lacunae and and uh
lapses in this presentation but
it is in fact um
curious that we find ourselves looking
at
campuses in turmoil again
the uh infinitely quotable yogi berra of
course is famous for saying it's like
deja vu all over again
um the the the spectacle of campus
protests and unrest
uh of the past several years suggests
just that remark
for those who if you'll pardon the
expression experience flashbacks to the
heady days of the 60s when campus was
where campuses were quite literally a
light with the flames of student outrage
student protest not so civil
disobedience and chemically enhanced
anger
the
english some of you no doubt are aware
of the english author and philosopher
roger scrutin
he he uh
credits the
parisian riots of 1968 with his dawning
self-awareness of his own conservatism
apparently he was overlooking these
riots in the street student riots in the
street uh
uh as as students are being chased by
police and he said i found myself
rooting for the cops
a little bit of self-knowledge suddenly
dawned upon him then um uh in my my own
university uh as you heard university of
kansas uh witnessed the torching of its
student union in the midst of student
protests a an event that perhaps argues
some confusion of priorities on the part
of the students to burn their own
building down it seems a little odd
i remember i wasn't there at the time i
was too young but but i remember hearing
about the university recruiting under
those circumstances the university
recruiting faculty to sleep in campus
buildings in an effort to discourage
student arson
now
this too suggests a rather charming
naivete on the part of administration
and an even more charming
unwillingness of students to exact
revenge for all their classroom tortures
knowing that
professors were dormant inside those
buildings um
but the the present surge of unrest of
course is not quite so materially
destructive as we witnessed in the 60s
i don't know why this is i'm not sure it
really matters perhaps one could say
that the current uh protesters are
lukewarm by comparison to their 60s
forebears
or maybe they're just more prudently
self-interested they're all if you burn
down the student union it's a lot harder
to get your lattes and cappuccinos and
chai teas
but the fact that we have this wave of
unrest carries i think some important
distinctions from the earlier turmoil
now these differences these distinctions
are not my point today but it is worth
pointing out that the protests today
seem to target free expression while the
earlier variety of protests at least
pretended to defend it the famous 1964
uh occupation
of the campus square at berkeley for
instance was expressly
in the name of free expression
um our protests followed decades of a
kind of internalized privileging of
victimhood
real putative or imagined while the
earlier spate of protests followed real
putative or imagined complacency about
social elites
our protests uh if you'll pardon the
paradox are essentially traditional
that is they operate in a now tradition
of activism protest and righteous
outrage
whereas the the tradition itself was
inaugurated in the 60s at that time they
were comparative novelties
but let's let's uh leave the 60s behind
and review a few uh more recent events
as a way of providing a context for our
uh remarks comments about free
expression and the fate of the academy
in our day
most of us remember uh people the the
student protests rather at the
university of missouri not long after
the ferguson episode which occurred uh
or achieved national prominence in the
fall of 2014.
at the university of missouri you
remember a large number of football
players refused to play refused to
compete unless the university president
resigned
his resignation was sought in view of
insufficiently vigorous
administrative action to counter
systemic and episodic racial antagonisms
eventually president tim wolf did resign
and this resignation rather than quiet
matters uh created a aftershocks of
protest at missouri but across the
country as well
i'm sure most of you uh remember reading
about the the um
resignation of claremont mckenna
college's student dean mary spellman
this occurred just last fall after
student protests denied or decried
rather her use of the phrase
our mold
in an email to a student who had
complained of inferior status attaching
to her ethnic identity
the dean had responded sympathetically
and encouragingly and invited
opportunities for further discussion of
such ethnic stratification at cmc
but the use of the phrase our mold was a
step too far and the dean had to go
interestingly this episode was followed
by counter protests on campus um and
it is curious that as we've seen in many
of these protests these uh campus
episodes the media coverage is not as
uniformly sympathetic to the protesters
as one might imagine there as i say were
counter protests at cmc and there were
some counter protests at other
institutions universities as well
nevertheless i think it's fair to say
that the climate across the country
remains one
by across the country i mean on campuses
remains one of a kind of edgy anxiety
eggshells and fear so to speak
um as fumes of these and other protests
wafted across the country the liberal
arts college of overland in nearby to me
nearby ohio
saw its own episode of student outrage
when a 14-page document addressed to the
president the board of trustees and
other so-called governing bodies
declared the institution unethical
after condemning it for various offenses
and after a very long list of demands
that included firing some people hiring
other people budgetary modifications to
the institution an end to curricular
hegemony and institution and also to
institutional gentrification
uh the document closes with this model
of diplomatic nuance
these are demands and not suggestions if
these demands are not taken seriously
immediate action will follow
rather than resign oberlin president
marvin krislov issued a statement
largely sympathetic with the spirit of
the document but insisting nonetheless
that i will not respond to a document
that explicitly rejects the notion of
collaborative engagement
well
a special irony i think attaches to
recent events at princeton again this is
something i'm sure you've all uh read
about which you're all familiar late
this fall students there occupied
president christopher eisgruber's office
for 32 hours demanding the removal of
woodrow wilson's name from the school of
public policy and the residential
college it demanded they demanded as
well cultural competency training for
all faculty
i'm not sure what that would be i'm
certainly not competent in my own
culture i'm still trying to achieve that
i'm not sure i'd be competent in any
other
courses on marginalized peoples and
designated spaces on campus for the
exclusive use of people of certain races
one i believe it was a student one
arthur devon published an article
critical
of employing racial bases for evaluating
opinion and for his pains he suffered
screamed profanities in public and
attempts to bar his attendant attendance
at a so-called open meeting
on campus to discuss
just these issues
now amidst all this president eisgruber
signed an agreement to write letters or
otherwise initiate processes to consider
the various student demands
the irony in all this especially as
regards the emphasis on safe spaces and
efforts to quell expressions
of alternate alternative or alternate
opinions is the fact that just the
previous spring in fact it was on april
6th the previous spring the princeton
faculty as a body adopted a statement in
defense of free expression in academic
environments a statement famously issued
a few years ago i think it was in 2014
uh by a special commission at the
university of chicago
so this is something of the context
these are not all the incidents they're
not even the most famous or all the most
famous ones um but it's it's it's while
it's not necessary to rehearse an entire
catalog
i think it's worth noting that this is
attracting more and more attention i
think the march 4th issue of the
atlantic uh has issue has published a
campus politics cheat sheet
that though not comprehensive lists a
number of prominent campus episodes and
references over 60 institutions
at which student protesters have issued
demands of their respective institutions
so what's all this about
what's behind this unrest this protest
these demands this attempts to uh these
attempts to to squelch the expression of
alternative views on campus
could it be that despite decades of
programming recruitment and policies
designed to assist underrepresented
classes of students to succeed in their
pursuit of higher education could it be
that systemic and structural inequities
of such a degree exist that reform is no
longer possible but instead we must
resort to as the students themselves
attest
revolution
burn it down
maybe maybe my uh suggested talk it's
over despair go home
is in accord with that sentiment
well the answer to that question of
course is yes depending on how one
defines such ineffable and subjective
things as systemic and structural
inequities or mechanisms
in other words the question itself is
not really meant to be critically
scrutinized but instead leads one down
an interminable path of dubious argument
and assertion
what one has got to do is try to get
behind these assertions and investigate
the culture and the practices that have
dominated higher education over the past
60 years or so at least as you will see
in order to determine what in what do
these events originate and i'm sure
you're all familiar with a handful of
conventional explanations right
one such explanation probably the most
common uh and by the way i think all of
these are true as far as they go i think
i think they're legitimate they're
important they're true
the first one i'm sure you're familiar
with is the spoiled youth thesis
uh that is our current college students
cuddled from the womb
uh uh they are deeply narcissistic they
are spoiled they are entitled and they
have no real apprehension much less
appreciation of the labor necessary
actually to succeed almost entirely by
one's own efforts that's
inadequate tracy of the spoiled youth
thesis then there's the lack of law and
order thesis again i think these are all
true as far as they go
taking possession of offices refusing to
execute one's contractual obligations
these and other actions are tolerated
not just tolerated they're celebrated
one university president actually hosted
called a a uh a sit-in in his own office
okay he announced we're having a sit in
in my office please come and sit in my
office so so
this is something beyond toleration
isn't it um such that there's no real
sense of accountability except to one's
own will
perhaps this is simply an extension of
the idea of spoiled youth uh but many of
the protesting students have little
sense of the failures
moral legal even diplomatic that their
actions put on display uh so that's
that's the law and order thesis i i have
to admit i thought of that one first
when i read about the football players
refusing to play i bet there are signed
agreements having to do with
scholarships i mean my first thought was
they're all on the scholarship they're
on full ride scholarships revoke the
scholarship
give them their bags and say goodbye but
of course that means a losing season
doesn't it for the football team
the third explanation we bump into quite
often the tenured radical explanation
faculty and administrators have for
generations now so overwhelmingly been
idle ideologues of a particular sort
that the university is finally
collapsing under its own weight of
anarchic forces
cutting off the branch on which they sit
the monolithically progressive and
radical academics are finally reaping
what they have sung again i think
there's something to that
um related to both of these is something
i haven't bumped into too often
in the media and that is
what you might call the poor educational
standards argument you know if you read
the demands so often issued by these
student groups
the thinking and the prose is exactable
i mean
i'm an english professor so perhaps i'm
too sensitive to these things but but
the level of intelligence on display is
embarrassingly small i mean
it doesn't matter if these are ivy
league students or not the the writing
is atrocious the arguments of
non-existence
if i were a university administrator in
receipt of such things i would hang my
head in shame but it wouldn't
necessarily be in shame
of of what was being
complained of but rather the poor
thinking the poor writing that our
students were were exhibiting for all to
see
well
the um
the the
the last it's not the last but that's
the last i'll detail here uh or mention
uh explanation is the somewhat more
obscure explanation having to do with
cultural origins
we've had for several decades now a kind
of cultural valorization of victimhood
this elevation of victimhood especially
when construed so broadly as to include
microaggressions invisible to the naked
eye
does allow for plausible claimants to
have a kind of special access to
political and cultural capital this has
been the case for some time now and it's
very very difficult to try to um
predict
what what sorts of avenues that kind of
cultural capital will will deploy itself
in what avenues it will deploy itself
and and i think we see the universities
and colleges uh attempts to rest control
of the institution and rest
expression from others who disagree
as an instance of the of such an avenue
in fact this last point brings us to a
very important
important
summary or umbrella
some commentators have noted that these
things finally really aren't about free
speech
or not directly they're not about
ethnic issues they're not about the very
real problems with respect to
discrimination and prejudice and bigotry
they're not about those things
they're
ultimately about power many of the
people involved are sincere and believe
that they concern these various
social ills but in fact what's really
going on is an attempt to rest control
of culturally important perhaps even
culturally dominant institutions of
higher learning such that a kind of
power
um uh
kind of execution of the will at will
can be had by a certain subset of the
demographic whether student or
professorial
so in all of this the unhappy news of
course is that free expression is one of
the first casualties it's a casualty
because of two things first of all the
uh free expression argument debate
discussion these are uh obstacles to
control these are obstacles to the
substitution of slogans for thought
right if if you are allow people to to
scrutinize your slogan airing your
slogan airing will be ineffective
uh it's also the case that that that
free expression is simply not considered
a good it's not considered a valuable
thing in and of itself uh it's worth
noting it sometimes people of my age are
perplexed and confused when the young
reject out of hand the value or
importance of free expression uh
but what we have to remember is to them
embrace of free argument in defense see
do you hear what i'm saying argument in
defense of
argument
right or free expression is acquaint old
social or intellectual piety at best
it's a value to people or for people who
who already have reverence for the order
of things that the so-called
revolutionaries want to destroy so
arguing in defense of free expression to
people who regarded as part of the
problem and part of the old order to be
overturned isn't going to get us very
far so as you see i think this is very
deep-rooted problem indeed
let's talk about those roots for just a
moment
for a century now or a century
i think our current travails with
respect to free expression are owing to
the
the promotion of free expression to an
educational end rather than a means more
about that in a few minutes but for at
least 100 years in the academy free
expression has been a kind of demagogue
it's had a
a privileged status not because it
allows for some other thing to eventuate
but because it in itself is a
self-sustaining good
this as the academy has largely fallen
except i think for the sciences has
largely fallen into a kind of
institutionalized
intellectual skepticism sometimes this
is simply referred to as relativism
although that term is usually applied to
things moral
intellectual skepticism is a deep
pessimism with respect to the mind's
ability to know
reality or the truth of things at all
in most disciplines
for many many decades now no real truth
or knowledge is at the end of all that
free expression
that is what we have is just a better or
worse
expression of
one's opinions truth is no longer
available this leaves a vacuum then in
an intellectual environment this leads
believes a vacuum into which the desire
for power as we have seen so vigorously
steps
by the way peter wood of the national
association of scholars has a very uh
good
piece on this very business this this
business of free expression as a means
or an end um he is referring to this
document produced by the committee on
free expression from the university of
chicago very good document in its way
but as wood points out one that doesn't
quite get to the root of the problem um
i i commend that to you
but what about
under these circumstances where free
expression is regarded as an end by the
old guard and regarded as an enemy by
the new uh where free expression in
other words where it's misunderstood by
all parties uh in in a context where the
culture has valorized victimization such
that if you want to achieve anything you
have to place yourself in a posture of
defeat in order to in order to be a
victor um
in these confines in the in these um uh
environs what to do how to restore
sanity well
again i was urged to advise you it can't
be done it's hopeless go home
but i don't think that's quite true
the first place to begin
is to restore the intellectual telos
to discourse itself now pardon me if i
lapse into a little bit of academic
jargon of my own but this is an academic
institution and we are talking about
academic matters that will be my excuse
anyway but i do beg your indulgence
so again restore the intellectual telos
to discourse itself free expression
properly understood isn't
a self-sustaining good or an end it is a
means to the end of knowledge
a means to the end of understanding a
means to the end of
a promotion of human relationships that
in themselves may be self-sustaining
goods so it's a means not an end
higher education operates in a context
of debate and argument for the sifting
of claims
and wherever possible for the
discernment of truth
understood in this way
we suddenly see that
a defense of free
expression really amounts to a defense
of the intellect's ability to know
and in fact it's responsibility to know
its need to strive to learn
um what's what's little understood if if
i can move on from that i know that's a
very important point but i'm pretty sure
everybody here understands the purchase
of that point pretty quickly pretty
easily
if i can move on to an ancillary point
that is not often regarded not often um
acknowledged or even seen it's the fact
that that debate and argument are
necessary not just for the discernment
of the real or the true but debate and
argument are necessary for the what what
you might call the continued vigorous
grasp
of the real and the truth that is that
is people who argue their way to an
understanding of a thing
need continued argument for that
understanding to remain
vigorous
or three-dimensional um
in in the 19th century john henry newman
used to make a distinction between what
he called notional apprehension and real
apprehension and the idea was that that
people can
can
come to an understanding of something
but in a very
abstract way
that doesn't seem to actually have much
purchase on their commitments and on
their convictions
a real apprehension moves the notional
into again a kind of concrete and
three-dimensional world and what very
few people realize is that truths
perceived require continued argument in
order for the perception to remain
lively vigorous again three-dimensional
so it's not just it gets you to a
discernment it renders the discernment
alive and continuous
that's i think an important point
simply extolling the virtues for reasons
i've already intimated of free
expression won't do
what you need to do instead is restore
to higher learning it's distinct and
identifying purpose so one you want to
restore to free expression its status as
a means rather than an end and then two
you want to restore to higher learning
its distinctive and identifying purpose
again over the past century higher
education has transformed its role its
purpose and its place
it has become
um
commodified you might say
uh it is a good which one purchases or
one's parents purchase or one's federal
government purchases or somebody
purchased this good but it it it that
education is a good that one goes out
into the marketplace and buys and what's
more
the good that one is buying is primarily
oriented to the acquisition of skills
that themselves are primarily oriented
to obtaining material advantages later
okay so higher education has become in
the past 100 years
a good which one buys
which good is skill acquisition for the
purpose of material
um advancement later this is commonplace
everybody this this is simply taken for
granted
um this acquisition moreover is
essentially an autonomous
solitary activity that's a very
important point we tend to think i'm not
saying it's true i'm saying it's how we
tend to think that
the acquisition of these skill sets that
you're then going to deploy for your
material advantage we think of as a very
solitary exercise one which we clump
together that is we assemble all these
students together for purposes of scale
or convenience but in essence what's
supposed to be happening is interior
solitary autonomous you might even say
corpuscular in isolation
how's that for jargon
well
the distinct and identifying purpose of
higher education
if i may be so bold
is to perfect
a personal
endowment of mind
to render the mind more deeply
susceptible
to the real
in other words it is to develop the
capacity and the habit of mind
whereby one grasps what is true in all
or in much of its rich
complexity
its implications its relations to other
true things
okay this is the identifying purpose
of higher learning
it has innumerable
skill set
implications entailments it has
incalculable consequences of practical
and material benefit and advantage in
the world but it is itself
a rendering of the mind susceptible to
the real i like to tease my students by
saying you you are a combination we
human beings are shocking combination of
profound
brilliance we can conceptualize
galaxies
billions of light years away
we can actually conceptualize those
things and yet look at you you're 20
years old and you're still sitting
behind a desk a dog is ready for life
after a year and look at you 20 years
and you're barely you're still wet
behind the ears
and the students they all shuffle their
feet and then they decide you know
wayland really is an old crank but um
the point is
we don't
recognize what is real and what is true
easily it's very hard for us it's
extremely difficult it takes years of
schooling and
i've been doing it for decades and
decades and decades and i'm still not
quite there right that's not false
humility it's really true that that kind
of susceptibility to the complicated
rich reality of the world it to be
grasped by an a knowing subject like man
and woman
that's hard and it takes time
so restore the idea that this perfection
of mind really only occur okay i'm gonna
take another step i i guess i should
prepare you for it
so so that's the identifying purpose but
it turns out this business of perfecting
the mind so as to render it susceptible
to reality
doesn't occur in a social context
by accident or as a matter of
convenience or even as a matter of
economic scale
we have to restore the idea that this
perfection of mind really only occurs
although this might be a paradox
in a collegial setting by collegial i
don't mean happy clappy i don't mean uh
friendly where everyone's you know uh
greeting each other with a ready smile i
mean it occurs with others
and with others necessarily
that is this kind of development of mind
if you consult
one doesn't have to take my uh word for
any of this consult your own experience
the development of mind i'm talking
about is highly dependent upon chance
and accidental encounters on convert
unscripted and unplanned conversations
and
such chance encounters and conversations
with others similarly employed
right with others doing the same thing
that you're doing it's inaudibly
inescapably social
this
cultivation of mind okay
these others those other people are not
mere atomistic accompaniments to one's
own pursuit
they require a binding together in
colleagueship in partnership they have
to be teammates as it were now i know
this sounds very sentimental or i i
worry that this sounds like some sort of
sentimental
appreciation of one's college years um
uh one one hears evocations of those two
a.m debates with roommates you know that
we all had that we remember so fondly um
but i don't think it is a sentimental
notion at all it turns out that one
cannot perfect
the mind without the participation of
others who are in pursuit of the same
end
look at this business of teams what what
happens in fact
um
if if you take
if you take this notion of partnership
or collegiality that is we are together
engaged in this
intellectual uh habitual perfection uh
pursuit that we're doing this together
if you take that away what people do is
they
they naturally seek it out in other
avenues so it's not a coincidence that
it was a football team
people who feel like they have
colleagues and a common purpose that
rise up together to announce this uh
it's not an accident that these these
are the
enunciations of groups and organizations
okay uh it's not so much the atomistic
individual that rises up and says i
demand this or i protest that it turns
out that they distill themselves into
units and groups and collections and
then they speak this is because they are
naturally seeking to as it were organize
themselves behind a common purpose a
purpose which by the way they sense
lacking in their education right
so what does this got to do with free
expression and the answer is absolutely
everything
we can't we know we can't simply extol
the virtual free expression the people
we're extolling it to don't believe in
it in the first place
instead restore the distinctive purpose
of higher education the perfection of
one's intellectual nature in a
necessarily collegial context and free
expression falls into place
inevitably almost automatically free
expression is a means to the end of this
perfection that we're seeking it is the
means to of the social engagement that
yields that that intellectual perfection
restore the end and the means necessary
to the end will fall into
place campus unrest itself becomes much
less likely in a context where those
present regard each other as colleagues
united by a common purpose
the the
the fact remains that if we if we
subtract this common purpose from higher
education if we simply result
dissolve higher education into
vocational preparation
and um
perhaps for the intellectually advanced
a kind of sophisticated
um
idiosyncratic curiosity scratching so to
speak
if this is what higher learning is going
to be and i do believe that's what it is
for the western developed world
then we can expect nothing but political
turmoil contention subject uh subjection
of the of the college and the university
to
uh fads and fashions of
power-hungry
micro-organized groups of one sort or
another it's going it's going to be
inevitable it's human nature it's what
human beings do
if you deprive them of its proper
orientation
then they will
take the mechanisms that lack an end and
subvert them as it were to ends other
than their own
does that make sense
you don't have to nod yes um uh
i i i think therefore at one at the same
time we have much to be encouraged by
because we are
talking about taproot tap roots of human
nature
but i am not a fool i know just how very
very far we are culturally from
understanding higher learning in
anything like the way that i've
described
that would be very very difficult to get
to from here but not impossible as i
think your presence here tests as
hillsdale college's presence here tests
um and has the good work of so many of
our graduates and students out the world
that's absolutely sounds like
self-promotion but i actually mean what
i say so with that i will happily
shut myself down and open the floor to
questions thank you
yes sir
all right thank you um
i was uh
you were talking i was thinking i bet
you don't have an i'm john galt poster
hanging in your office
but i was so well um right to propose
like the individual versus the
the group
so you say that it takes
you know a functioning collegial
atmosphere to create say good citizens
or
because i would suggest that it's the
the people coming to the college
that make it what it is and just as
english literature every most things you
read are written by one author
so i mean can can you take people
and make them a group more than the sum
of their parts or are you limited by
what goes into it
uh good question yes i think you can
first of all
it's true that higher education is it's
dependent it comes at the end of a long
history of education right that is some
some young man or young woman has had a
lot of schooling before they get to
college or university and um that means
you're inheriting a whole set of
presuppositions and expectations and
that's that's certainly true
however
my own immediate experience suggests
it's
quite astonishing what one can do in the
space of four years
that is one can when can bring a student
again because i think we're dealing with
human nature uh one can bring a student
who has very atomistic
presuppositions about what he or she is
up to and then bring them into an actual
vibrant intellectual community where by
the way this is not disneyland not
everyone is a friend right not every
personality is clash people have
preferences and tastes and students love
to hold other kinds of people with other
kinds of interests in disdain right you
know human nature is not left at the
door of the campus right when when
people enter but nevertheless those same
students who think oh [ __ ] oh the jocks
what are they up to um those same
students will regard those so-called
jocks as
as having more in common with them and a
more common loyalty and a common pursuit
than perhaps somebody at the you know
faceless state university up the road so
so
in fact i would say yes you you can
you can bring people a very long way
people who aren't expecting it people
who don't look for it but who find their
own natural aptitudes and
shall we say the contours of their own
natures are
respond to that kind of environment
quite well quite well surprisingly well
i'm usually not very hopeful about such
things but but uh direct experience is
undeniable
yes
thank you
so since publication i think most
memorably bullying alone a lot of this
has been made about the decline of
community in the united states in
american culture basically it's saying
that people are more as you put it at a
mystic than they ever have been before
and i guess to what degree do you see
this playing into the decline of the
academy it's it's it's right at the
heart of it um
the
there are two things i identified two
things that have sort of subverted the
purpose of the academy the first is um
uh
the prevalence of intellectual
skepticism frankly the despair uh i
don't mean to be
uh irreverent or
um
crude but i often record i often call
this intellectual skepticism a kind of
cogitatus interruptus right you know
it's all this thinking but nothing at
the end not nothing to think through
nothing to think to
um
uh
that's one
facet that's a deprivation of the end of
higher learning but but accompanying
that deprivation is
the um
a new end right the end is simply
some kind of vocational ad equation
skill
adoption to allow one to be more
productive in the world and by the way
all those things are good skills
productivity all those things are good
but if that becomes the end then that's
that's self-referential to a degree that
the previous end having to do with um
pursuit of this this
perfect perfection of mine this
intellectual habit
as newman calls it in a social context
one it becomes more atomistic so the the
the
kind of desiccated
autonomous individual
who just accidentally is collected with
a bunch of other people
and in pursuit of vocational training
purely
that's at the heart of the matter and
when i say the heart of the matter i
mean the heart of the threat to free
expression on campus because free
expression in that context is
superfluous it's unnecessary it's it's a
it's sort of like saying uh how
important is uh
uh orange marmalade on campus
right it's it's it's uh extraneous it
has nothing to do with the nature of the
beast now if you restore the beast to
its original or uh understood purposes
and by the way i'm not naive i
understand that the people entering
higher learning
or all of human history at least since
the creation of the university in the
middle ages did so with very mixed
motives and
all kinds of
um
vagaries of purpose but nevertheless the
cultural understanding of what was going
on was enough to shape
an enormous amount of everybody's
experience in the academy
so it comes down to this those two
things
the loss of the end or rather it's
replacement with an uh
an inadequate end
and uh loss of the understanding that
that end the proper end is achieved in a
in a social or uh community context
that's resulted in free expression
becoming uh deeply imperiled look it's
just going to be subject to whatever
powerful force wants to come in rest
control of this engine a university is
an engine it's a machine it's a thing
and it it has operations and it has
effects wouldn't it be nice if you
controlled that
you just owned it
wouldn't that be nice and here's this
talking and argument that gets in the
way shut up
we're going to do things this way and
we're going to do it based on a claim of
victimization
it's very simple i think i don't i don't
really think it's it's terribly obscure
yes
that's now why did you have to go ask a
serious and probing question
yes why the question is um what is the
answer to the valorization of
victimization um there there are
there are two commonplace answers to
that question uh neither of which i
think work one is well
stop victimizing
stop victimizing if we can just get all
our social mechanisms arranged properly
there will be no more victimization and
then the problem of its undue
valorization goes away
uh the other the other answer i think is
a little better a little deeper and that
is
oh gosh we don't have time for a lecture
um
where does the valorization of
victimization derive its impetus its
capital its energy it derives it from a
desiccated form of christianity right
that is um
tell an a pre-christian roman or or
greek person that you know losers are to
be pitied so to speak you know the
person who lost the contest
you know the the the hero is a man of
martial excellence not a man of pitiable
um he's actually pitiable in other ways
ways that surprise the the hero but but
what what what christianity brings us is
understanding of the inherent value and
dignity of of persons by virtue of being
persons not by virtue of being
successful or by virtue of being heroic
or by virtue of being powerful right
they're they're of infinite value by
virtue of being persons images of god
well take god out of that
and you have
the weak
and the
and the the downtrodden and the
victimized deserving kind of what what
it really turns into is the
sentimentalization
of something that had been
a supernatural charity i don't have time
to develop the thought but the idea is
restore
that
due appreciation for hardship and
difficulty and restore to that it's
supernatural
impetus and significance and then and
then you um you
you escape the kind of
uh social and political polarization and
the the
consequences of that that we see
i i think that's i think there are lots
of truths buried in both of those but
the reason they're inadequate is is that
they um
they're
forms of wishful thinking
right um uh it's all very well to say
well if the world would just
convert to a properly christian
understanding of uh the role of charita
yeah
the conditional is what is the
difficulty there um uh so perhaps
perhaps a better answer would be
the um
a non-frontal assault
right so how do we restore free
expression on campus quit talking about
free expression restore the campuses
identity
its nature its essence to the campus and
then lo and behold you'll wake up the
next day and free expression will thrive
right
same thing with the valorization of
victimhood instead of trying to
devalorize victimization i mean people
actually are victims there really are
social ills there are things are wrong
that need to be corrected so so what
kind of foolish
policy would it be to attack that as it
were head-on instead instead what you do
is again restore the institution in this
case we're talking about universities uh
higher learning restore higher learning
to its proper
purpose and the romance shall we say the
attraction of valorized victimhood
turns out to be thinner and thinner and
thinner gruel until finally it's just
pitched out
it's it's astonishing how many things
how many baleful things derive their
energy
from
um misdirection
just reorient a thing to its proper end
or direction and a host of ills just
fall away of themselves
yes sir
mal klein accuracy in academia
um
what do you think of the idea of holding
universities liable to truth in
advertising laws
hillsdale could handle it
well
we
truth in advertising um
i'm i gather by that you mean things
having to do with graduation rates
placement rates uh student debt that is
should universities publicize um
what actually happens and what are the
consequences of attending a given
institution for a given period of years
is that what you mean
right right i see
well
the um
i appreciate the point the point is
shouldn't universities
and colleges be legally required to
to
be scrupulously honest in all of their
public relations
and the answer is
no
i don't think they should be legally
required they should be morally required
uh and by that i i i don't mean to split
hairs what i mean is the law is a clumsy
blunt instrument
we've we've spent decades now trying
here in this town we've spent decades
trying to get the law to do fine social
work for us by social work i just mean
modify our common life together in fine
detailed ways and it makes a hash of it
it just makes a mess of it um
the the law is not the instrument
uh to move
universities and colleges to a more um
transparent and scrupulously honest
expression of their own natures and
identity i think a reawakened moral
understanding of the actual intellectual
formative
purpose of the institution would would
do that better uh at the same time
people um you know when when i i live
and work in a college
when a young man
is going to take the young lady out on a
date it turns out he washes his face and
he shaves and he puts on better clothes
than he usually does it's it's not
surprising that
uh institutions as well as people put
their best face forward when trying to
attract or appeal uh to someone
so i maybe i'm a little too forgiving of
that
yes sir
last question i hear
hi my name is brian miller i work at the
center for individual rights um i just
was curious what you just said about
laws and morality i tend to agree with
you but um
in a lot of the examples you mentioned
that have been in the news recently
students like you know
storming the president's offices and
occupying grounds on the university
these are violations of so many
university policies
and uh
if a conservative organization were to
try and do those things they would be
shut down immediately and organizations
like mine go around the country
telling universities that you know their
speech codes are unconstitutional they
need to like drop all these rules
but is there like some
role for university rules or for law to
play where maybe we need to tell
universities that they actually do need
to enforce
the rules that are on the books
well
the um
that's a that's an interesting point
there are some rules on the books that
shouldn't be there that are
unconstitutional and unconscionable uh
and then there are lots of rules on the
books that are are
perfectly sensible such as fulfill your
contractual obligations uh and and yet
are ignored or not met
so you're right in some cases you want
them to
abide by the rules in some cases you
want them to throw the rules out uh so
there's some fine tuning needed uh but i
i do think the um
i do think there is a
terrific and almost bottomless
maybe even unfathomable failure
of of
will
of courage
that is universities that allow for just
a flagrant violation of all kinds of
social policies and by the way many
institutions are over regulated
by themselves not even by the gov they
don't even wait for the government to
regulate them they regulate themselves
into a kind of paralysis that's that's a
management issue that's a management
problem i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about fundamentals such as
someone refusing to uh
uh to
um
act on his or her
voluntarily assumed obligations okay
someone
fundamentally failing to live up to
their contractual requirements
certainly universities should should um
demand that those requirements be met or
the consequences of any broken contract
the fault right so so i i do think there
is a place for much more vigorous rule
enforcement on campuses and in fact
the lack of it i don't think is mere
cowardice or
lack of thumus or something like that i
think the lack of it is the
now decades-old inherent sympathy on the
part of faculty and administrators with
the kind of social revolution the
students are pursuing right uh they're
they're uh they're in many cases wishing
the students success let me organize a
a sit-in in my own office let me advance
let me show you how to properly protest
this and get some good media coverage
get some
some free publicity for your cause let
me help you with that there's a bit of
that going on as well
i don't know if i adequately answered
your question but that's a good one i
understand that the lunch hour is over
and so we must conclude thank you for
coming